[Music]
when Rihanna signed on for the Super
Bowl halftime show her pregnancy was
apparently a secret from the powers that
be
[Music]
a source telling E.T the NFL and apple
music had no idea Riri would be rocking
out for two challenge that I was willing
to accept well being a new mom nothing
would have gotten me out the house if it
wasn't a challenge like that well we
don't know yet how far along Riri is it
couldn't have been easy pulling off
moves like this while expecting
but a source tells E.T Rihanna's always
done things on her own schedule and
didn't let a little baby bump get in the
way of taking on one of music's biggest
stages quote she wanted it all
foreign
[Music]
we also don't know if Rihanna even knew
she had a baby on board when she
originally signed on for the Super Bowl
she had just welcomed her first child a
few months earlier when I first got the
call to do it again this year it I was
like
you sure like I'm I'm three months
postpartum like should I be making major
decisions like this right now like I
might regret this but it's when you
become a mom there's something that just
happens where you feel like you could
take on the world you can do anything
we're told she did clue in a very
limited few people just ahead of
Sunday's performance and everyone was
very supportive the Super Bowl is one of
the biggest stages in the world yeah
it's an Entertainer's dream to be on a
stage like that but it's nerve-wracking
well it didn't show on stage the star
brought her A-game to State Farm Stadium
her big return to music after seven
years
[Music]
my God
I think it was just
her wanting to make the statement that
she could carry this thing and she did
and people would just want to see her
and so she had to give him a show and
she did choreography we haven't seen her
dance like that in a long time and I
thought it was just spectacular those
dance moves our source says they were
tweaked up until the last minute along
with Rihanna's costume she wasn't gonna
be ready until it was absolutely perfect
you want to get it right you know
everybody's watching and they're rooting
for you yeah and I want I want to get it
right well reread delivered and it was
nothing short of iconic
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm still pinching myself really I'm
grateful I'm grateful
foreign